comme amine el bahi oncle de deux
enfants détenus en syrie bonsoir amine
el bahi merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous qui avait précisément
un neveu et une nièce retenu en syrie
est ce que ça vous redonne de l'espoir
ce rapatriement
bon ça alors ces rapatriements ne me
donne pas en soi de l'espoir ça laisse
supposer ont envie que le l'appel des
familles que nous avons lancé depuis
tant d'années et effectivement entendu
et que le combat que nous menons au
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois aux
côtés des juristes des ong doit se
poursuivre mais il veut dire que même
votre attention sur le fait que ces
rapatriements d'enfants sont
principalement des rapatriements
d'amphores cela pourquoi le gouvernement
rapatrie yeux des enfants orphelins
parce que naturellement la question du
retour de leurs parents ne se pose pas
puisqu'ils sont orphelins aujourd'hui
nous militons pour que l'ensemble des
enfants français c'est à dire plus de
300 enfants français soient rapatriés
dans les meilleurs délais dans notre
pays cette amérique y compris quand ils
ont effectivement encore leurs parents
c'est justement votre point bien
évidemment moi je crois que il n'ya pas
de distinction à avoir entre les enfants
qui serait orphelin ou ceux qui seraient
détenus avec leurs parents et d'ailleurs
j'aimerais d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement s'explique sur sur la
vulnérabilité de ces enfants en coin
enfant colin se rivent d'autant plus
vulnérable qu'un enfant d'exercer
pendant qu'ils sont tous détenus dans un
camp où il ya plus de soixante dix mille
femmes et enfants dans des conditions
sanitaires déplorables contraire au
droit international et sincèrement entre
nous je pense qu'il faut arrêter avec le
cynisme du gouvernement français qui se
départit de tous et de toutes
responsabilités alors qu'on sait
parfaitement que c'est caen qui se situe
au nord-est de la syrie sont surveillés
par des cubains eux mêmes soutenus par
une coalition militaire internationale
dont la france
d'ailleurs la france a elle même investi
de l'argent dans ces camps pour les
kurdes et on le sait pertinemment que la
plupart de ces enfants qui sont des
lieux dans ces camps vivent dans des
conditions horribles horrible et ja dire
sincèrement l'attention du gouvernement
et des manuels mac ou qui refusent
depuis deux ans de répondre à nos
courriers qui rend plus de nous recevoir
qui refuse de recevoir les avocats pour
eux échanger ensemble et trouver une
solution diplomatique
est ce que enfin ce n'est pas une
question si j'imagine évidemment vous
êtes conscient de l'aspect sensible du
dossier on parle souvent voilà ici ou là
d'enfants de djihadistes il ya une
méfiance on dit que voilà tout
simplement leurs parents avaient la
haine de la france il ya une forme de
méfiance quant au retour de ses enfants
par certains qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez justement c'est d'être acteurs
quels arguments vous pouvez leur donner
je ne réponds pas l'opinion de me jouer
pour responsables politiques parce que
la question n'est pas une question d'âge
les politiques font aussi en fonction de
l'opinion publique
oui enfin vous savez si on l'avait
demandé me l'aviez l'opinion publique
sur la peine de mort encore aujourd'hui
nous serions sous le régime de la peine
de mort donc moi je ne demande pas la
vie publique je demande au gouvernement
de prendre son courage politique à
demain et je dis très sincèrement que le
gouvernement maintenant deux ans reporte
et 6 me de rapatriement parce qu'il ya
les élections il faut le dire très
clairement on parlait déjà d'un
rapatriement en avant les acquis puis
après avant les européennes et
maintenant nous sommes là rapatriement
après les municipales - sincèrement je
pense qu'il faut arrêtez de politiser la
question parle d'enfants il faut revenir
aux fondamentaux nous sommes la mère
porteuse et des de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et jeudi
à l'opinion publique à un moment il faut
prendre en compte que ces enfants n'ont
pas demandé à naître ou être emmenés sur
zone ils ont tout perdu ses enfants au
tirage au sort de la naissance et ses
enfants qui veut dans 90 % des cas sont
âgés de moins de 6 ans ne ferait pas le
moindre mal à à une personne sait
parfaitement que ses enfants sont
innocents et ils n'ont rien demandé à
personne donc il faut aujourd'hui cessé
dégoûté des caricatures de l'extrême
droite qui sont d'ailleurs aux prises
par le gouvernement à bon escient
concert quand ça lui va il faut se dire
que ces enfants ont moins de 6 ans
qu'ils ont tous leur à venir debreu que
la france a déjà pu prendre l'enfant en
compte et en charge les enfants qui
avaient été enrôlés au rwanda ça se
passe super bien aujourd'hui que nous
sommes l'une des premières démocraties
au monde et que nous avons des
institutions capables de prendre en
charge ces enfants de les éduquer moi je
crois en notre modèle de gestion et j'en
avais les premiers pas vraiment coupé
les premiers sont rentrés il ya deux ans
en france qu'elle est entre nîmes et le
retour d'expérience sur ses enfants
comment vont-ils dans quelles conditions
vivent t-il alors une fois que les
enfants sont de retour en france il ya
deux possibilités
la première c'est que les enfants soient
prises en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance d'ailleurs il n'y échappe à
tous passent par le l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et devant un juge pour enfants
qui détermine d'une part leur
responsabilité pénale alors on sait très
bien que l écharpe un de ceux que 12 ans
et qui d'autre part évaluer capacité à
s'intégrer dans la société et ensuite au
goût de deux ans ils sont remis à leur
famille en or très souvent aux grands
parents ou un sombre
en tout cas la famille proche de façon à
ce que ces enfants puissent se
rehaussent ya lisez puisque ils ont vécu
le beurre les enfants des camps ils ont
été détenus et moi je pense que nous
devons en france tirait aussi les
conséquences et les leçons de nos
histoires
moi j'habite à roubaix vous savez dans
une commune où où beaucoup de jeunes
parents d'enfants immigrés ont vécu
notamment le savez la question des
harkis qui avaient été des u11 exane ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui sont des danses
et quand on t'a notre histoire
d'ailleurs et honte à la france
aujourd'hui de revivre cette même
histoire et de ne pas reconnaître que
des enfants sont des enfants et sont
clairement innocent et moi je pense
sincèrement que nous devons être
capables de prendre en compte la
vulnérabilité de ses enfants ses enfants
peuvent être intégrés dans notre société
ces enfants sont suivis par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance par les psychologues
par des professionnels par des experts
nous sommes en capacité de les intégrer
dans la société pour tout le monde le
dit y compris les services socio
judiciaire merci amine ben avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france